he's at least getting his pieces out
oh oh my god he made me there
i i saw it at the end oh god
okay
[Music]
let's jump right into the the technique
exercise and
here's what we're gonna do i'm gonna
challenge you to a game
um of two minutes at first we're gonna
start that way
uh two minutes for both of us okay i'm
going to dictate to you the first
three or four moves to make in order for
you to reach
uh the position of material if that you
know like what you used to do with the
queen odds except
i'll also give up both of my rooks at
first
and then from there you'll start playing
so this will take us like 15 20 seconds
so you'll have about a minute and a half
once the real game starts
okay are you ready buckle up because
i know this is gonna be torturous at
first but
mark my i think this is going to
actually help quite a bit
and i think it's gonna be a lot of fun i
mean for me of course
we're extremely watching you freaking
yeah you're gonna
you're gonna pop off with just like a
[ __ ] row of pawns or something and
take every piece of yourself
god forbid an exercise that's fun for
you i mean jesus why would i ever do
that
okay so i just challenged you all right
folks here we go
say your prayers
where do the challenges go again uh it's
in the play but if you click play
up on your top yeah and some idiot i see
a challenge okay so
go knight f6 knight f6
take the queen go d6
take my rook go bishop e6
take my rook and begin the game okay
good luck
here come the ponds peach
all right i forgot i'm on a time limit
okay oh yeah
one thing i'll say preliminarily and
then i'll shut up and let you focus
if you lose a piece for example remember
you're up so many pieces don't get
broken up over that try to keep the pace
and if you're losing a piece try to
sacrifice it for as much as possible
okay that sounds good
actually doesn't do anything but i can
at least say that ion was haunted
against
turbo fisto yes yes yes yes
that is pretty prestigious oh extremely
the greatest honor
you know what else is the greatest i saw
that fork yeah [ __ ] i'm playing
again follow my advice yeah don't panic
yeah so you're good you're good okay now
i'll shut up
thank god i thought you would play queen
g1
oh you lucky little you can also win
this
that's it's called out playing dance you
wouldn't
you wouldn't understand that you're i
know
if you lose this game on time you are
going to no
pain i can assure you i most likely will
be losing on time
uh
oh come on baby only two moves away from
checkmate he had checkmate in one move
believe it or not
from that position we don't need to go
into an analysis word because you
actually did everything
very well um and this was better than i
expected actually
so navigate over to move 22 after your
brilliant queen f1 check
you're i mean which is going to be
enshrined in the hall of fame of chess
moves
it did i mean i i mean i in my wildest
dreams i could not imagine so black to
move in this position
oh it's just going right here right two
i'm just not looking at
the announcement so are you saying yeah
exactly we need one mini one so
this was made and sort of the one thing
that you want to focus on here other
than you know you applied the sort of
advice while you like didn't get broken
up over any pieces and you continued
playing well
as soon as you open up the position you
start looking for checkmate
don't tunnel vision free pieces because
you already have a lot of them
you don't need to take freaking more
pieces you have extra
entire kingdom so you need to kind of
keep your eyes peeled out for checkmate
okay yeah let's do that again
yeah no i didn't purposely not take the
queen i pre-moved king d2 basically
yeah you'll have to go to play again to
accept the challenge
oh back through the menu believe it or
not it's in the same place than it was
okay e4
knight f3 take
knight back to f3 take the rook
um go back to f1 with the bishop
okay go back to g1 with the knight
take the rook okay start playing
okay i muted myself in the call so i can
actually do that
the sad thing is he's up to rooks and
this is a legitimate strategy you can
give up your queen to basically get rid
of all my pieces
um but he didn't do it intentionally
which basically makes it
null and void um and
you know this is going to be a painful
exercise but it is what we need to do
like he has to start following his
instinct there's no other way
and he's playing well right now he's got
a minute he's actually look at how fast
he's actually playing and he's playing
very decent modes
so he has it in him he just needs to get
it together
f4 f5 now he's got to be aggressive
let's see if he does it
let's see if he does it taking his time
okay four bishop g4
move the rook okay i'm gonna block it
i'm gonna try to make it as difficult as
possible for him to make progress
and okay i can't go h4 i can't try to
intimidate him
he's he can even sacrifice him do you
want oh no that one is a pawn
um he's up two rooks just g4
one yup good move
okay everybody let's pray
okay he wants to go here i'm gonna run
with my king
my king
thank you z cons z cons i recognize that
name somewhere thanks for the sub man i
appreciate the t1
thank you guys for all the support
you're amazing
okay this is unrated all i need is a
rook
okay he's still completely winning you
might maybe he actually sacrificed it
he's six here wins
okay good wow i'm telling you he's got
the instincts yeah from csc
oh i know who you are oh my god can i
i don't want to say your docs are full
your first name but i i know you are
wow small worlds
high school buzz okay charlie's going to
lose on time
charlie is going to lose on time
that's okay we're going to do this until
he starts winning i don't care if we do
this until
4 00 a.m we're going to do this until he
starts freaking winning
he can make a draw by perpetual
oh sacramento no no no no say it's
okay i told you this was gonna be
torture
yeah i had an idea it just didn't work
like i thought it would you sack the
queen did you like give it up
deliberately
no well i thought i could do a legals
move or something but i
i think it was more just a time thing
and not looking properly
so funny i think the rook on purpose at
e1
funnily enough you are playing too fast
in the opening and the too slowly at the
end of the
you can take a little bit of time in the
opening and look at we don't have to do
an analysis board look at the position
after move 1394
because you're up so much so many pieces
all you have to do is simplify
you don't care about pawn structure i
don't have a queen to deliver checkmate
with so
how can you basically force a trade of
as many pieces as possible either the
knight on d4
or the bishop on c5 what would be the
best way to do that
i'm just going to the outpost at d5 be
possible absolutely or developing the
bishop to e3
you see that would basically you would
either take the night with a bishop or i
would take your night with my knight
and then you would trade another pair of
pieces okay that's sort of the chief
strategy the other thing
is so i would not have sacrificed that
other rook i would i mean
you can just move it to like move 33
goes to move 33.
move 33 you could just play rook to c1
uh the only reason you would sacrifice
in these odds games
is to for vast simplification did you
think you could deliver checkmate or did
you think you could promote the pawn
it was i wasn't going for a checkmate i
wanted to yeah i just want
i kind of get got into the position i
had in my head towards the end there but
it just didn't work
so the best way to go for checkmate
would be to actually keep pieces alive
in order to checkmate
um which is a mind-boggling concept but
you're doing actually you're playing
fast i you know
we can cut the torture as soon as you
want but i think this is actually very
helpful
um are you okay are you traumatized to
the point where you can't continue or
can you
no can you keep uh biting the bullet
here okay
i believe let's go okay um the challenge
you tell you the moves and then
uh same drill basically okay um knight
f6
take my queen uh d6
take the rook bishop e6
take my rook start playing
all right i'll move myself so obviously
i have a couple extra moves which
uh complete moot point because he's up a
million pieces
he's already gotten off so great so i
lost the bishop already um
great okay um
but the thing is like he's up so maybe
he's that
even taking one of my pawns is fian can
be good oh god
oh god he trained thanks for the sub man
okay he's given two pieces up he's still
completely winning
um but he is
okay he just needs to develop he's
still the problem he's played too fast
in the opening he has still
played too fast but now he starts the
thing but he's already blundered his
pieces
i'm gonna try some legals mate business
i'm actually gonna try to checkmate him
okay he's giving everything up he's he's
tilting here
i was actually close there oh my lands
he just lost
okay that was terrible
so you know what i just brought what i i
own
two of these items
it's a thing that you like put on your
pants to tighten them up i'm holding it
up right now
okay and i'm waving it around
it's it's called a belt ah yeah
no that sounds about right just run it
back let's forget that one happened
okay okay okay i like it let's just wipe
that one from here
because of that mentality i'm gonna i'm
gonna keep the belts
on my pants for now okay so let me
one just remember you're still playing
too fast the first couple of moves are
pivotal
once i get all give all the pieces up 10
15 seconds just to orient yourself
open up the position and not blunder
anything is crucial
okay um i challenged you
uh e4 um
knight f3 take the queen
uh d4
take the rook bishop back to c1
knight back to f3 take the
rook start playing
you better win this one now i i can
sense that he's not happy and i like it
i love it actually
i actually blow it no
okay i don't want to trade but i have to
okay so basically my strategy is to keep
as many pieces on the board as possible
um my my strategy is to keep as many
pieces on the board as possible
oh he's he's mad charlie is mad he he
wants to win
and i love it busting the position open
with c4 would have been good here but
he's actually playing much better here
this is the russian way of teaching i'm
going to put him under the freaking
ringer
until he starts winning okay um and and
he's
just got to learn this the time
management and the confidence
that just has to get better and the
instinct has to get better and
i've never done this exercise before
there we go queen f3 that's freaking
right bishop g6 is the three he's
when he's pissed we all saw how he
played on the pog champs amazingly
when he's pissed he can play like a 13
1400
easily easily
um now would have been a good time to
sack the bishop and bust the position
open
that's another thing that i'm not sad i
feel like he doesn't have a great grasp
right now on sacrifices when does he
sacrifice and when not to sacrifice
we will work on that as well um
i'm not tilting him i mean he has a
chance to win and feel good about
himself there we go
here we go now we're talking this is
what i'm talking about
knight b5 is a great move and good time
management so far now let's not ruin
okay take the i don't know why rookie
why doesn't he take the pun
this is where he starts panicking he
sees like two pawns and he's oh my god
like let's see if he can avoid the panic
he can even double on the e file and
just take everything on e5
let's see if he sacrifices just sack
everything on yeah
that's freaking right okay
okay this is called chess
now check maybe let's see
rookie a okay rookie seven is good
enough there's nothing i can do here
take the pawn
and finish the game with checkmate rook
g7
is this freaking kasparov or something
watch him ruin this he's taking too long
made me on d5 already
that's what i'm freaking talking about
that's what i'm talking about
that was actually that was great okay
and the time management was perfect
can i make like two constru i don't want
to like split but i have two
constructive comments here
about what went right and like and i
would you know the
only thing that i wasn't as happy there
was like one or two moments but i think
they'll be instructive so let me invite
you to a ward but
i feel like when you get like bad you
you're you can play like a 13 1400 like
easy
what is a good way to like always make
you mad like every game
that's my secret i i'm never mad this
wasn't me playing mad this was me being
embarrassed
i feel like i don't know i feel like
there was that freaking
fight right there okay so i'm inviting
you
now it's funny like people on people who
don't know what i'm doing right now
um i feel like my family members might
get concerned if they're watching me
on chess.com they're like um what did
daniel ingest today's
blundering this uses every game just
occurred to me that i might need to do
some explaining so
okay um now what did you do well here
you didn't you weren't afraid of puns
you gave up on strategically to simplify
okay great development one comment here
i would use the pawns to just bust the
position open it
make everything explode how can you do
that use one of your pawns
just to to trade and make open up the
center before
yeah so c4 then queen a4 and just it's
over
that's one thing to consider perfect
perfect perfect
another instance where you could
sacrifice a piece
in order to bust open the position
basically win immediately try to find
this move
and relatively speaking because you're
up so much you can
absolutely afford to you know to to do
this
so with the i think the move is the one
that i had in mind before you move
king there i was just going to take this
pawn if you played something else take
on g6 you couldn't take back and then
just go in like that
exactly so you would do that anyway go
ahead yeah so it's still doing that it's
still good
yeah and then i take the bishop i don't
know if you've made the okay it doesn't
show
so i take
and now and then
yeah so then after that uh i'm looking
to
[Music]
where what has changed as a result of
the last one what is hanging now
yeah now i have a pawn hanging so i'm
coming in with the rook right it's over
over immediate look at your pieces at
close quarters the game even sexier
would actually be and i just actually
saw this
you can do the the other order take on
e6 with the rook
then take on g6 with the bishop what are
you threatening the checkmate
yeah yeah exactly so that would have
been even faster but
this was all good could have taken the
pawn back by the way
yeah i did i had seen that i said that
i was like muted on my stream saying is
he going to see the fact that he can
just take everything on e4
bust down the iphone you [ __ ] did i
mean this
is great okay this move is redemption
and the last thing is that you take a
little bit too long actually just you
screwing around a little bit too much
here so here for example
um just start giving checks and it's
going to be made okay find the fastest
mate here
use all of your pieces and and just
finish finish the game off
okay so it's bringing the rook down
first it's c8 right
but but here's the thing the rook is
cutting off the king the rook is very
valuable in the seventh rank because
it's
keeping the king on a square where it
can essentially be easily dealt with now
first thing you can do is pin this
knight and win it and check me
fine okay so so we're going to d5 with
queen
first then or you could give a check
and in this position i want you to find
the mate and two moves
it's bringing rook over first deliver
that check yeah
and then take so you know in the same
vein check on d5 here
so when you have a rook on the seventh
that's cutting off the king on the
eighth
you rarely want to allow the king access
to the seventh rank which is i mean
bishop p7 was fine i should have moved
my knight out
i felt like you were dragging this on a
little bit so you can be more confident
when you're like
literally have the king alone and you
have a million pieces like that
okay that makes sense a little bit where
i'm going to challenge you to a 90
second game and we're going to make the
initial moves in about 10 seconds
okay and um ultimately
you should be able to win this i would
say in 45 seconds or so
but you know that's a that's still a
little bit in the future okay custom
one minute and 30 seconds okay unrated
challenge
okay knight f6 oh [ __ ] no no no sorry
oh i gave you odds now i have more time
than you have let me abort
what how is that impossible you see that
you had a minute and i had
oh wait one minute how is this possible
time okay let me try zero minutes at 90
seconds
okay try again
the hell is that okay perfect e4
knight f3 let's take queen
knight f3 oh jesus take the rook
sorry i don't mean to be that intense d4
d4
d4 uh bishop f1
back to his initial square take my rook
start playing okay
this is obviously going to be a
challenge but we'll see how he handles
it and
yep perfect that's freaking right bust
it open quickly check made me don't give
me even a chance just develop pieces
right i mean this is fine
this is fine he's giving up a pawn c4 is
good you're just chasing the night away
c4 is good here castling totally fine to
develop now
the challenge for him i think is going
to be like actually delivering the final
blows rookie one x-raying
i'm going to try to keep as many pieces
on the board as possible
i hope you guys are enjoying this um
it's an it's something new i
you know i don't know if it's going to
be effective i
make mistakes too in my instruction but
i think that it's really just going to
help him see
that he can he's well he's he can find
moves
when he's really uh locked in okay
training 95 activate knight c3 to d5 is
also good
yeah knight d5 is good here just put the
knight on that on an outpost trade it
and when you yeah this is perfectly fine
as well hey proffer
yeah so i'm going to try to develop more
of these exercises for him
um just to make him a little bit more
fluent at a playing concept i think he
knows a lot of concepts but he sometimes
struggles to
figure out how to 95 the fact that he
thought for like 10 seconds here i don't
like
queen e8 check go go take the pawn
mate me stop thinking this
just go take the pawn that's good enough
i'm going to try to scare him knight g5
is basically made in a couple moves here
he's taking too long but finding the
move
take f7 take f7
taking too long he's thinking he's just
taking too long
he's not gonna make it now i mean this
is just he has made him too but he's not
gonna see it
i just had no time [ __ ] so same problem
here you came very close you had made in
a couple
the moment where you took too long and
again we don't need an analysis board
here
is move 24 okay and i noticed this you
have 21 seconds
just move like take the pawn on f7
you see what i'm saying you're spending
way too long
trying to find the exact mating sequence
and what i want to make very clear to
you is that if you just
activate your pieces and put them on
good squares and check me
it's going to end up being made you have
enough instinct where you don't actually
need to see
the exact mate but you cannot you spent
10 seconds on move 25 from 16 to 10
from six that you can't do that yeah
that's the key
you want to try 90 seconds again yeah
yeah okay i think you can do this um
but the key is to you can take your time
at the start but at some point when
you've busted things open
follow your instinct is the key
okay um oh sorry
okay so uh knight f6
take queen back to f6
d6 take the rook
bishop e6
take the rook and start
okay i'm gonna keep this going here
bishop c4 he's already what a great
start
great start blending the bishop okay and
this is not gonna end well
this is not gonna go on it's okay this
is just the first time we're doing this
exercise
now he can take on f7 and win easily now
this is actually a very good move here
taking is actually a great choice now i
the reality is
i'm not actually maybe i bishop e6 the
reverse merman thanks for the
he wants to get checkmated doesn't he
crap i missed this one actually now
let's
let's go back to g5
the belt is here yup queen g4 i really
like
got to defend this spawn somehow thanks
reverse merman thank you so much for the
sub
um the hype is strong today guys i
really appreciate
support let's get this to 2500
amazing okay so knight c6 yeah he he
narrowly avoided disaster now i would
just sack the queen for e6 honestly i
would just sack it
and he's he's go okay he sacks it this
way but
probably missed it okay now that's not
good now he gives the knight up
he loses loses his cool in these
positions somebody just doesn't
retain his calm when when one thing goes
wrong
h6 probably okay
i'm telling you i can just sense it he
drops his
loses his calm completely and we need to
work on that he needs to improve thank
you cranked for the sub
now i'm actually objectively better
whoa lodges tier three how many pieces
is he gonna blunder
lodges with tier three sub holy smokes
yep
how did i can you guys explain something
to me how did i end up with two extra
pieces when i start down a rook okay
he's tilted
i think we made a mistake i think you
gave me peace odds
yeah yeah that's i thought that's what
you said we were doing
right right right right right so was
that not what we were doing for this one
well no i was i mean okay because i
wouldn't i wouldn't even be
i'm very impressed you were able to
overcome that so
let me make one thing very clear you're
not going to have long-term success in
this
in this um exercise until you realize
that you have to spend at least
10 seconds on the first two three moves
okay you played the move bishop c4 move
eight immediately you blundered the
bishop and that's how everything started
where should you put the bishop
just bring it back all the way back if
you want bring the bishop to c8 bring
the knight to g8
start with a start from scratch but when
you blunder that piece the other thing
is
and and guess what you played the move
e5 move nine again two move
two seconds blunder knight g5
okay and then you actually played very
well but
after bishop e6 moved 51 did you sack
the queen
or did you blunder it blended it 100 so
if you wanted to sack the queen and
eliminate as many of my pieces as
possible while you were at it which move
could you make here
just take the bishop take the bishop i
only have two pieces left
go ahead and do so always keep that in
your mind the other thing is
i mean then you kind of started just
wondering everything at that point it
was already not so clear
but yeah you have got to spend some time
as
counter intuitive counterintuitive as it
may appear the first five moves are
pivotal
if you get through them you win 99 of
the time
okay yeah all right again because
i don't accept that as a game that makes
sense
so i i can see why
this better be good oh sorry um aboard
let's try it let's do it again my bad
i muted myself by accident oh no worries
um okay uh e4
uh d4
d4 knight f3 take the queen
back to f3 take the rook
back to c1 take the rook
play when i play g6
i was actually thinking he's gonna sack
my queen
okay let's see something good here
this is unacceptable game
that's right now he's going to win this
game mark my words and i'm not going to
like try to lose i'm going to play i oh
you guys see that i actually try really
hard
to to make it difficult for him i'm not
trying to do this to make him look good
because what are we doing this for at
the end of the day
now i said 10 seconds i didn't say 30
seconds i didn't say 20 seconds i said
take 10 seconds at the start
not five hours but let's see how this
works out for him
well the question at the end of the day
um that a lot of people actually
say no to is do you want to feel good
about yourself
or do you want to get better at chess
because the two are
um not mutually exclusive but you
you cannot prioritize the first and
truly
embrace the second so that is the
question that you have to ask of
yourself if you're serious about
improvement
whoa i'm eating nachos as serious about
gifting subs as he gifts five of them to
the community
thank you i'm eating nachos
thank you thank you now knight tv busted
open charlie bust it open
taking too long he's taking too
long and now i told him 10 seconds i
didn't tell him 50.
okay but he actually still might win
he's he's in good shape
d5 d5 do it see it
cd5 okay decent
freaking long i mean when is he going to
realize that there is a sweet spot
um and as soon as he realized that he's
going to win he still might check mate
me
i'm going to try to escape through g7
yeah it's over
okay that never played too slow that
time you played too slow but i want you
to notice
how much better you played and how close
you came to the mate
so where did you spend too much time i
you know
so let me see you spent 13 seconds on
move 11.
the sweet spot is to spend five seconds
or so and i said on the first five moves
once the first five moves are made
and you're out and and good you can
start playing a little bit faster
the other thing is you are still being
too reluctant about busting things open
just
right crush everything open go to move
number
20 after you took on d6
go to move 20. you see rook on e1 it's
pinning the pawn on e6
how can you bust the position open
i just push up the pawn d5 bingo and if
i take with the bishop
i just take exactly so you played much
better that time
but you know too much time you have to
constantly be looking at your clock
if you're down like 20 seconds that
means you need to just start playing
really quickly
okay are you down to take another uh
beating yeah i'm ready i'm always ready
okay let's go because this is
trust me you're gonna be bruised um and
pissed but you're going to come out come
out of this stronger let's go
okay i'll tell you the moves knight f6
take queen back to f6 d6
take the rook bishop e6
if you play bishop c4 and the starting
position you just don't try because
start
all right i'm gonna take the scissors
out if that happens yeah
okay yeah but whiplash is the
is too much i mean not quite my tempo
but i'm not trying to be like terence
fletchers i'm like i i try to be at
least somewhat encouraging and at the
same time
i think there's russian actual russian
coaches are
be like literally abusive this is
actually really good
um so the key is to find this this
balance where you're like harsh and and
you say the truth but you're also like
you you um celebrate their
accomplishments the same time
okay i'm gonna try to intimidate him
fake intimidation
but i appreciate your guys's kind words
so queen d7 is good here just get the
bishop out
get just get your pieces out like he
oh starting to overthink it you can just
see it on his face you can see it in
time
he's starting to find some sort of thing
that's not there rather than just
getting his pieces so
20 seconds on the move he's spending 20
seconds on the goddamn move
he should have done this in two seconds
okay and now i'm gonna i'm gonna just
throw a couple of intimidation tactics
at him and he's just gonna spend another
30 seconds and lose on time
yeah yeah i don't care we're gonna do
this until he starts
starts winning i i do have an elo goal i
think that
okay i mean look at this
now those of you who are like charlie is
stuck remember that pot champs
one was like three months ago and the
guy had never touched the chessboard
before then so
you know i i'm not i don't think we're
in a rush i think that he can be
right 12 1300 within the next couple of
months i think that's the realistic goal
for him
start pre-moving start pre-moving
knight a5 knight c4 but
at this point realistically you should
already start pre-moving
at this point you should realistically
start pre-moving we are facing the demon
in the eyes we're performing an exorcism
right now it's not supposed to be pretty
it's not supposed to be pretty we're
performing an exorcism right now it's
not supposed to be pretty
but we'll get this demon out so
where did you spend i want you to go
through the game and tell me
which move you spent too too long what
was the move that killed you
because you started perfectly
it was moved through 23 seconds
on a development move okay yeah
what were you thinking about uh
well i was just looking at a way of
winning a piece i noticed knight bishop
on the same diagonal i was just looking
for a way to
so you didn't have enough already queen
and two rooks but no you need
goddamn need that piece
it's a necessity for life so another
good thing there
would have been to prepare castles so
queen d7 and then castle long would have
been good
another thing you could do is just play
h6 and get rid of that knight
but the move bishop h6 move 14
there of course it gives up the bishop
but i would play bishop g7 their fiance
the bishop so simpler development
gotcha yeah simpler development
okay let's go
e4 knight f3
take queen back to f3 take the rook
i like how you have these down already
back to f1
d3 take rook start
yeah we have like perfected we have
perfected this
okay he's gonna i can feel it too he's
gonna he's
he's got it he's got it whoops oh my
mouse left ml slipped i didn't mean to
do that i put my meds by knight a6 but
okay this is fine
we're gonna drop our bishop back here to
stop down but should be five here let's
see it
taking his time good good
i mean this exercise is is is going to
build his his speed his confidence
it's going to show him eventually that
he's got the instincts to take him to 12
1300
but he's not combining them in the right
way so
hopefully this will help okay
now again i've never done this
particular exercise i've never worked as
extensively with someone of charlie's
reading
so this is a learning experience for me
as well i am also
hopefully going to become better at what
i do and uh
this is a lot of fun for me to see how
the various things we do impact his
his play he does need to play bullet and
blitz i agree yeah
he will need to play some more three
minute chess knight d5
what is that what is that why
how do you blunder like that perfect
play move
for 16 moves now he's gonna panic and
start throwing me everything he's gonna
take on h5 or something
okay there comes the 15 move there comes
the 15 second think
here comes the 15 second thing there we
go and he's gonna think for 20 seconds
and lose on time again f4 is a perfectly
good move
now move your queen if this move should
take one second you should
queen is hanging with the queen
e5 let's see if he finds e5 bust it open
just like we talked about okay fine
bishop g5 is good
take c7
yeah i am lose i am close to getting
whatsoever i can do whatever the hell i
want i can
i can invite a zebra into my apartment
and he'll lose on time
because he's not pre-moving he's taking
one second per move here now he's
playing perfectly
he's getting closer and closer he's
almost there
there's always just that one move where
he thinks for 30 seconds
okay we're gonna add a wrinkle to this
exercise
if you think for 15 seconds or longer on
any one move
one second let me see yes i will
go back on the call and force you to
resign that game okay
so you're believe it or not you're
actually getting better and better
okay and the reason that we're doing
this in the first place and why i
believe that you're going to start
winning and once you win that first game
you're not going to lose whoa
i did win one we did but i mean you're
going to win consistently you're going
to start winning
and first of all you had that same move
20 go to move 20. you missed another
chance to just bust things open
how do you do that again using the pin
i just take the knight right even use
the pin to open the center
you you've basically the same thing as
you could have done
a couple of games ago i just pushed the
pawn up to e5 then five and do you see
i want you to make the moves on your
board we don't need to in analysis board
there's just one very quick thing takes
takes right bishop bishop e5
then you put a rook on e1 a knight on d5
and
mate you know it's just me
so the thing that is exacerbating
your chances is that you're trying to
kind of go around my pieces
rather than just blasting things open
you could have also put a knight on d5
earlier
so turn the aggression dial a little bit
you don't even need to sacrifice
anything
but you need to look for more
opportunities to open up the center the
other thing is
as soon as you spend 15 seconds or
longer on a move the game is over
ready ready
let's see some brilliance knight f6
take queen back to f6 e6
oh that's fine no it doesn't matter
doesn't matter it's all good uh take the
rogue
back to f8 take the rook
all right this is actually kind of funny
okay go
i tried to play a trick on him by saying
go to encourage him to play quickly but
i like that he took some time bishop c5
there
that's right this is it now he's gonna
play too fast and he's gonna blunder all
of his pieces watch it
or maybe he'll actually do it right this
time
yes you'll have to email me i am as i've
said teaching wise i am really
booked up right now so i don't have very
much availability but you can still
email me and i will institute a waiting
list and
you know so i i'm still figuring all of
this out guys it's been
it's been seven months since i've
started teaching full-time so you know
i'm still a rookie at
a lot of the logistical aspects of it um
but you know
this is great so let's go e4 he can even
play e4 and open up the d
file i don't have any pieces left bishop
g4
we're going to make this harder the next
game because i'm going to take up the
center and we're going to see how he
does it then
okay
good i'm going to try to avoid trades
bishop e6 here is good it's like every
move should accomplish one of three
things it should either involve a piece
into the game
trade a piece or um
or bust open the center
uh loafs really i was under the
impression that i went through all of my
emails
um and responded to everyone but i will
um
check that again you might have to email
me twice again if you saw my inbox i
think you would be maybe a little bit
more sympathetic
toward me missing an email here and
there i don't have a secretary
so if you've emailed me and not received
response please just email me again or
just keep emailing me until i do respond
i don't get offended at that
move still he's still
too slow i mean i'm gonna break
something right now
move your bishop
okay where did he spend too long i mean
look at this
this is [ __ ] take the knife take the one
take the bishop
okay i didn't take 15 seconds though
so um two moments
perfect opening 13 seconds on move 14
bishop g4
why again you're developing a bishop you
have done this
hundreds of times in addition to bishop
g4 you could play bishop e6
trading bishops okay when you've already
gotten rid of one piece
you can get rid of you can start trading
and then that makes it easier
i trade that for stay though right
because you still have b5
but then you chase the bishop with a6
and i have to either take your knight
or get my bishop back what do you think
it is and i'm not trying to like
i'm truly trying to get to the bottom of
this is it do you feel like you're
trying to find the perfect move and
comparing moves or are you like drawing
a bit of a blank and trying to figure
out how to put your pieces no there's
never i'm always looking at multiple
moves and i think that's
the problem so my challenge to you is
the first move that you come up with
after you check that it's not a blunder
you play it okay yeah i'll that doesn't
mean you play instantly
and it doesn't mean you like make random
moves you can still think of a general
plan
but you follow your instincts virtually
on every move
okay let's go
e4 knight f3
take queen back to f3 take the rook
you're like the probably the world's
leading expert at making these moves
fast
bishop e2 d3
take the rook begin
all right he's getting there trust me he
is going to get there and then he will
reap the rewards of this
for his the entirety of his chess career
first move that comes to mind
what was his time situation when he
started if he thinks for 15 seconds the
game is over
how did anybody see how much time he had
that's it okay resign
that was 15 seconds uh why don't you
resign and then we'll see i think that
was like more like 20.
what that was let's see if i'm wrong
you can the belt the belt can come out
that was 25 that was right on the dot 17
seconds
before when i told you to resign no
[ __ ] way look what 22 122
and the moment i don't even i don't see
that where do you see that
so when you just play through the game
on your stream you see there's the
timestamps look 122
57. so i told you to resign at around
the one minute and three second mark
i gave you even some extra time why
didn't you take the pawn
as soon as i offer a trade you take the
pawn you develop the night
what were you thinking about i was i
well again i didn't know if it'd be
better to develop the night first and
take with knight and hold that or just
take the pawn and make that
it's like your every game is like you're
skydiving you have the parachute you
know it's working
and you just don't jump the moment you
jump you will experience
bliss of unthink you will experience
unthinkable list when you realize
how good your instincts actually are
god that felt like literally maybe six
seconds
also holy [ __ ] hundred bucks from sg
um for abusing this for i appreciate it
man nice
all right um
um one second my mouse is malfunctioning
just give me a second i'm challenging
you
something is wrong with my computer
what's the hell one second sorry i said
some
i cannot see my like cursor
thank you so much man um
well well thank you after i beat the
[ __ ] out of this guy
oh okay
sorry my computer is like hardcore
glitching right now
oh there we go okay we're good
uh challenging you
we're good okay um
let's go knight f6 take queen
um e6
pawn e6 back to f6 with the knight take
rook
bishop d6 take rook
back to d6 start the game after my next
move ready
yup okay uh i don't know if you guys can
see okay yeah i'll cut i'll correct it
all right
uh so let me thank you properly i got a
hundred bucks from sg12589 love the
content thanks for all the work you've
been
hoping to have a lesson you one day
thank you so much my man
one of benjamin thrown my way right from
sg i really appreciate the support
you're the man you're the man i
appreciate it
can you guys still see everything did
anything get misaligned i feel like
something got misaligned
yeah some stuff got misaligned guys i'll
just have to fix it later
okay
a6 move move your ass
this is good this is a very promising
beginning and
i'm going to try to prevent him from
going d5 queen a5 checks see the queen
get it out knight b4 is good
queen b6 get the pieces out of the
bring stuff out okay did anybody okay
great
and he's actually the great thing is his
instincts are literally he's making the
moves that
i would make knight to d4 yeah that's
freaking right you take that pawn
and you finish this b5
d5 it doesn't matter knight d4 okay
check don't give me this check
knight t4 bring the knight back bring
the pawn back bring it into the game
knight b4 is fine okay i'm gonna try to
hunker down here and defend sack busted
open b5 bring the pieces in
okay i have to go forward knight c2
trade the knights stray the knight queen
c1
oh 94 94 see it see the pin
see knight takes c4 please see it see it
see it see it
how many times do we need to go over the
concept of a pin and then a mobile pawn
see it
ah
oh my goodness made in two
yeah that was just the issue so go to
move
perfect play for 20 moves for
more than 20 moves move 23
and you spent so move 23
two things first of all find you have
checkmate in two moves from that
position
and your achilles heel tactically right
now has switched from forks to pins
i feel like you're just not looking at
the pins in a position you have to look
at them
move 23 find it
but that's not actually what i'm saying
i understand what the pins are this is a
move that exploits a pin
i see so i wasn't even looking at the
left side of the board
so the pin is obviously the d3 and i
only looked at what i could do at c4
it's taking here
right and that it can so make the move
on your board on your stream
king moves back to the first rank and
now you have checkmate on the next move
which is what did you make the move
i did it's not an analysis board so like
i'm just telling you what moves to make
so
move the king back to either d1 or c1
and then find the mate
and tell me what it is
it doesn't matter which one it doesn't
matter which one it's the same mate
yeah so it's just bringing it all the
way back to a1 bingo
and so but that's i don't care about
that 14 seconds
from 25 to 11. if you don't know what to
do
it there should be like a decision to
like a checklist right you don't know
what to do
bring pieces in the move b the move b5
that you made is a good move
but that should happen within three
seconds [ __ ] i don't know what to do
i don't have enough pieces in the attack
bring more pieces in how
b5 get the bishop out sacrifice i don't
care
you see now the improvement is the first
15 moves were literally just like
perfect e5
you went night before brought the queen
in gave a check took the pawn
your instincts were perfect um it's
it's literally the long things that are
getting to you um and trying to find
that perfect move when you're on the
cusp of checkmating
but if you solve that you're gonna win
this game
okay that sounds good all right so we're
getting there we're getting there we're
getting there we're getting there
okay e4 knight f3
take queen back to f3 knight c3
or yeah it take sorry i i did
bishop f1 d3
take rook begin after my next move
okay this is where men are made
this is where freaking this is where
it's made this is just this is simply
where it's made
here we go okay what is going on with
the
okay whatever i'll have to align this
thing later guys something something
glitched out on my computer you have to
take
okay let's go b6 d4 go bust it open d4
let's go d4
that's what we like to see this is what
we like to see bishop b5 he's already
winning
take the knight take the pawn bishop g5
end it
let's go
now will he see queen d7 with mate
think the knight is fine you can just
take the knight here it's totally chill
knight c6 castles just don't give me
this trick now i've
prevented it don't look for beauty
f3 i don't care yet whatever just just
made me
too long he's spending too long take the
knight mate me already take the knight
move the knight doesn't matter i i can't
do anything so take the knight bish
queen d5 okay g4s
fine but i don't i'm not liking where
this is going and celebrate it
prematurely move
95 back to e5 move get your pieces out
how many times do i have to tell him to
get his pieces out when he doesn't know
what to do
and it's just like it okay now this is
basically mate will he checkmate me
it doesn't matter where you move it five
seconds too long
check castle mate me castle
get your pieces in bingo
it's made in a couple moves get your
knight into the game mate me
knight e5 takes f7
cut me off
he's not gonna make
this is the closest i didn't even know
it's impossible to get this close so
your problem is very specific it's
you're on the cusp of delivering
checkmate and the same should starts to
happen so
six seconds it's panic
and where does it come from because you
don't get the pieces into the attack you
try to meet with like
you're cutting your own nuts like it's
like okay so go to move
26 no actually go to move so first of
all all of this you should have done
faster 23
move 23 moving the knight should have
been one second
what you can do on move 23 okay
queen to d4 then rook to f1
and the other rook to d1
bring all of your pieces in and the
checkmate is going to become a lot
easier and you're not gonna have to
spend time to find it
okay that is the only modification you
have to make you're trying to find like
v
checkmate rather than just blasting
everything open
another thing you could have done um
move
uh 29 29
95 and knight takes f7 if you take that
pawn
it you know the king becomes a the king
is just the one
right okay now you're there
now it's time to deliver when you're
actually mating other than that
keep everything you did there knight f6
take queen back to f6 d6
take the rook bishop e6
take the rook oh sorry bishop b6 but
should be six
oh [ __ ] just okay it's okay i just put
d7 like
those extra five seconds and move bishop
e6
okay you're making stuff around yourself
rook
and after my next move go
okay the sorry let me just mute myself
okay so the oh god sorry for the
misalignment guys i don't know what's
wrong
okay
i'm gonna at least have time to reflect
on everything
okay whatever i'm just gonna leave it
this way for now
i'm gonna leave it this way for now no i
don't care about my time
develop your pieces stop thinking
we're going to do this until freaking
2025 until he realizes
this one i mean there's just like two
things he needs to realize i'm gonna
take which i have nothing else to do
he's in the gulag right now he's in the
russian freaking gulag with the work
camps
and he's he's toiling away and he's
gonna come out stronger
he's in the gulags
one second guys
sorry
okay i'm going to get low on time myself
to try to tilt him a little bit
okay something is wrong this sound
oh god okay there we go move
move your ass bishop h6 move move move
please move castle good
good the queenie one
infiltrate and move again this is
exactly where he spends too long look at
the time
look at his clock god damn it b6 what is
this feeble little b6 i mean just
get to it queenie one
oh [ __ ] cannot beside me oh my god he
actually sighed
get the king and get the rook in get the
pieces in
[ __ ] well ah
i made the move it just wasn't fast
enough russell c3 it's made in two there
yeah
yeah so and this could have all been
avoided with there was really
literally only one move you spent too
long on 10 seconds on move 21 and b6
instead of queenie one move 21 queen to
e1
ends the game immediately infiltrate
wait uh move 21 queen to e you need one
point to e1
um yeah jesus okay
it's good this is improvement we're
going to go for 10 more minutes or so on
this exercise then unfortunately i have
to go
but no worries hold out for 10 more
minutes and
i want to see the goddamn first win and
the second win in that time
that's okay very good it's e4
knight f3 take the queen back to f3
uh bishop e2
just yeah sorry i'm by myself going
crazy take the rook uh bishop back to
its initial square f1
um how do i give this circle knight g5
g5 g5 okay okay take the rook
and then go back to g5 and back to f3 in
one move okay d6 back to g5
okay back to f3 knight c3 and then start
okay just to give you that development
okay
good big that was yeah okay here we go
bishop b5 d4 so this is he we've already
had this type of position before
now he's spinning okay d4 is good
well the reality is
the reality is i mean
he's we have already seen the improve
compare this to the first games that he
played
we were losing on time on like move five
he's basically winning in every game
but bishop c4 oh that's an actually
really nice idea
that's a really nice idea queen d2
defend the knight bishop d4 is good here
bishop d4 too long too long too long too
long
okay fine this is fine this is actually
a good move well i have to
try to take some material back now i
can't avoid the trade of bishops
yeah i'm busted if he just plays five
moves correctly why is he thinking about
taking the bishop good
this will definitely be on youtube e5
e5 e5 e5 e5 if i make a move
again he misses a chance to open up this
open
up the position there we go bingo
take it e6 just
it's like this leap of faith that he
refuses to make and until he makes it
it's all it's just going to be hard for
him
e6 e6 okay so now i'm now he
if he doesn't make me here i'm going to
like i i don't even know what i'm gonna
do
okay charlie get your queen and what is
he thinking about
he's gonna lose on time three seconds on
this move i mean are you kidding me
he's gotta pre-move this free move
i have a simple question for you when
you have six seconds
um so you have 7.0 seconds
and then you have 3.4 seconds on the
next move
you can't allow that tab again another
perfect game and again the same [ __ ]
happened where
you get to move 27 with 17 seconds left
you spend five seconds on the move
rookie one instead of
involving the queen that's on a1
bringing it to d4 and then to g4 and
delivering the checkmate yeah that would
have been a lot faster yeah
you realize that you can give away as
many pawns as you want
and you need to bring all the pieces in
it's going to be a struggle trying to
finish the game off
um and you're still in your mind you're
clinging
to i i feel like you're clinging to like
this notion that you need to find like
the method rather than just throwing all
the pieces into the attack
right okay
let's go um
okay so let's do um knight f6
take queen uh d6
oh sorry i i literally just removed it
it's all good d6 on the next move
take the rook bishop e6
take the rook and start on the next move
okay
good d5 is good i'm gonna take the stem
okay this is exhausting but it's um
we're gonna do this again of course he's
six
he's gonna get some freaking 15 1600
there's no doubt in my mind that
the prerequisite to him getting to to to
heights
on scene for someone who has not played
chess until his age and is a
very successful individual and streamer
like is he's gotta
as long as he continues to train and he
continues to play and he's interested
there's no reason he's not going to end
up being 15 1600 eventually
there's just no reason he's not um i
i will be happy to continue providing
instruction to him
for years i like i'm enjoying this
but the key is like he's just got to
keep keep keep getting interested and
you know if you're from his chat um and
you're you're in his chat you know you
encourage him
and be kind and and the fact that he's
willing to
undergo this speaks a lot about a person
um and
his fortitude so i believe
i believe um i will be there for him to
in as much as i can to to help him
improve as long as he
is willing to continue
and i'm busted and this is going to be
the first one i feel it
okay he sacks the rook which actually is
a good idea this is actually a great
idea now this is made
just take the bishop knight g3 queen yep
okay the thing that a lot of people
don't realize
is like it's not easy to
fail even though this isn't failing this
is learning but
yeah it's great it's great this is i
think it's gonna be very helpful
exercise again he's taking too long and
he's gonna win
oh my god it's mate okay
maybe one see it
did you take on purpose like what did
you take to make sure i saw the
checkmate or did you not see that
did i take well i had no alternative
it's mate either way king e1 queen b1 is
also me
i did not know that so no at that point
i mean g3 was dumb but
this is a huge moment okay now it wasn't
perfect
and the one criticism i have bulldog
thanks for the gift is after knight
takes d5
move 20 you got a little bit too excited
recapture that damn night
don't give up too much stuff and then
you can take the pawn
so it's like two dials that you turn
right and
one is like how much do you sacrifice to
bust open the position
and you gotta adjust that dial just
right the other is like
um you know well yeah that's basically
the one thing that you have to adjust
just right
okay okay which uh which move again
sorry
move 20 knight takes d5
okay so just take it back instead take
it back take the knight back
okay so you down for one last one
yeah for sure let's do it
and i better see consecutive wins good
job this was this was very well played
and uh we'll draw some conclusions
afterward
sounds good oh [ __ ] e4 e4 u4 [ __ ] sorry
oh i muted myself okay okay
knight f3 take the queen
i mean this is like turbo back to f3
take the rook
back to initial f1 knight g5
g capture rook and then you're gonna go
knight back to g5 and back to f3
you can pre-move that back to g5 back to
f3
and after my next move begin
okay last game guys then i'm gonna head
out
i could be back at two for a
continuation i'm going to ask if he's
still streaming
at 2 15 i could be back um
but um you know 220 or so
we'll see
there's so much more we have to do
though there's literally like there's we
have to learn openings we need to do
positional stuff
um we have a lot of work to do for for
him to cross to the next level
realistically uh to 1200 but
we'll get it done knight five move move
move knight d5 bishop g5
make a move
take f6 knight t5 i mean he's just
crushing now take f6 take the knight
yes yes take c7 see it see it see it see
it see it see it's
okay fine knight five didn't see the
pawn
take h5 okay i'm gonna chase this queen
around okay good
i mean i'm going to try to escape as
much as possible he's taking too long
still but it's gotten a lot better 95
95 this should be five
this should be five quickly see it
bishop b5 develop
quickly five seconds is too long okay i
have to go back
i mean okay great look at the quality of
his moves and look at how much it's
improved
his time is not good and we need to
still work on that
don't move the knight quincy a bust it
open f4 f4 f4 move move
move
yeah it's over but okay
one more you got it perfectly again
there's
always i can pinpoint one move where you
took too long and that loss due to the
game and that move was
one second it was smooth 25
yeah 18. it does you can even not move
the knight and go queen c8
okay when you eliminate that one move
you're gonna start winning every game
okay let's do one last one
okay this better be good
let's go okay um knight f6
capture queen uh back to f6
d6 take rook
back to e6 take the rook
begin after my next move
all right this better be a win
okay we're going to do this again 200
bits thank you so much for the five
gifted stuff sorry i i didn't thank the
amazing
support that was coming my way uh you
guys are the best thanks uh everybody
who just gifted
and subbed
um knight c6 developed charlie develop
no i i do i do have to go and i'm
i actually have a lesson my student is
very graciously waiting um
so to me my lessons are so
you know crucially important for me to
be able to hone these skills
take the knight so
you don't get one without the other
folks you don't get one without the
other
move move move why what is if i could
make a brain scan right now this move
should have been happened it should have
been done in one second
bingo two pawns hang he's got to take
this one
knight c6 move bishop c4 let's go
this is what this is this is this is
what we call chess
boom take the take the bishop he's
thinking about this rather than just a
trade i'm going to try to psych him out
here don't give me a check on d1
move the bishop back and he he did it in
two seconds
knight c6 develop when in doubt develop
develop develop
too much time too long but he's
developing he's bringing the pieces out
we just need to figure out you know we
need to
just clean that up a little bit that's
the move that might see
six what get the night out
get queen knight pawn checkmate move
queen g1 bust it open
oh my goodness okay he might have
sacrificed it
he's at least getting his pieces out
oh oh my god he made it me there
i i saw it at the end oh
god okay i'll i'll give you an a minus
for that because of two things
you quickly got your pieces into the
game
um when sort of in doubt
um what we need to work on and
the improvement has been huge if you
compare this to your first couple of
games
um the thing that we're going to
continue working on is
first of all like the move c6 move 22
right look at that move what is the
purpose of
your instead of that one you should
develop your knight to c6 and get your
get your night out i immediately
regretted that i think that was just a
panic move because i knew i was taking a
long time
the others yeah 10 seconds on move 11
but basically after that very very good
bishop c4 was excellent
um and the only other criticism i had
was yeah i mean your time
time apportionment was with c6 you took
six seconds rather than just developing
the night
other than that the instincts vastly
improved
the time management much better with two
minutes on the clock you would it would
be incredibly easy and you'll see that
we'll start with that the next time i'll
give you two minutes and you will see
once this sinks in and you internalize
it
you will win effortlessly um so
um yeah so unfortunately i i do have to
take off for now
charlie but i think it's a good time
anyway to for you to sort of process
everything
oh for sure yeah this is great man you
were right i think this was very
instructive
you know i apprecia i do appreciate that
you were willing to go along with this
and uh
this is not the last time that we all do
this exercise
yeah it's good to me because it's one of
the top priorities right now for us
and uh you know we've got a lot of work
to do for
you for you to cross you know 1200
there's openings we need to
we need to look at and review um we need
to work on your instincts
a lot more but overall i'm really happy
with the progress and
you know you might not see the results
immediately but you will during our next
session i give you my word and uh
there was great improvement so i'm
really happy with today's session i
think i think we did some good work
yeah i think this is a good idea thank
you man absolutely well um
are you going to continue streaming yeah
i'm going to keep going for a little
while i will
as a small reward i will definitely give
you the raid that's the least you
deserve after such a battering
but um yeah that was great um and
um you know you're gonna you're gonna be
you're gonna have nightmares about what
we're gonna do the next time so
good luck well good work today
um and uh hopefully uh we can do this
again soon
oh good to me man yeah absolutely
fantastic um
thanks again for sticking out with it
and uh and and
continuing to do this i admire that so
i'm doing it it's always fun man all
right we'll have a great rest of the
stream i'll send you some thiefs your
way as well
thanks man have a great day bye of
course see ya
all right well that folks was the
session with charlie i mean it was a
memorable session wow what i mean what a
session it was i
i'm very happy with the way that turned
out i think he's going to be 1200 pretty
soon so
very pumped at his progress
[Music]
you